hello I'm um James 1 I'm a person who
doesn't get on very well with mics so
have anything wrong with this mic let me
know I'm also from IBM Research in
Zurich and I work on quality viewing and
I work on our open source project called
kiss get for doing quantum computing so
in this session I'll take you through
some very basics of quantum computing
and kiss kit and it's a so workshop so
you can you can run code along with me
there's free free plans for how you
could do this
so you the repository you can find at
the other end of this shortened link so
go there and you'll get to this
repository obviously you can see the URL
at the top as well so yeah you can
download or you can clone this
repository and it has some duper and
notebooks in that you can know I'll be
using as a basis for this presentation
so if you have the ability to use duper
and low books and you have Python free
then all is well with the world there
are a few packages you need mostly it's
like numpy and but it's also matplotlib
for which for me is very normal but
maybe not everybody uses it
Plan B is we have this cloud service
that you can use from the hosts to
promote books and then everything is
already installed there it's a nice
environment where everything has already
set up obviously it needs the internet
and so it's that's why it's not plan a
because it doesn't go without its
hitches
also not absolutely everything that I'm
gonna be presenting is is able to run on
their cloud service but Plan C is not to
run anything you can just sit and watch
and learn about stuff and then go on to
to do things later ok so what I'm first
gonna do is give a little bit of a an
introduction to what quantum computing
is and do so we have you know fancy
pictures and buzzwords
just to motivate what this is all about
and at the bottom there which hopefully
people can see the bottom is this
shortened link to the repository so at
any point you can always go and have a
look at that
so yeah I'll go through this well also
while you try plan a and Plan B and
resign yourself to Plan C and then we'll
see what's going on at the end okay so
the first thing to know is well quantum
computing has the word quantum in it and
if you watch films then well for me
sci-fi films often seem like fantasy
films except you replace the word magic
with quantum and that doesn't really
help quantum computing because we're an
actual technology able of doing able to
do stuff but people have this
misconception that it's somehow strange
or chaotic or unpredictable so it's it's
not it's a science and we can use it for
things and the motivation behind quantum
computing and this is something that has
been known since the 80s is that there
are some problems that are just too hard
for current computers and the classic
example of this is is simulating quantum
systems if you have a relatively large
system like a molecule then the amount
of memory it takes to store the possible
States for a large quantum system is
huge and then a number of operations you
have to perform in order to simulate a
large quantum system is also huge so you
get to the point where you have the kind
of molecules that you might be
interested in from the perspective of
drug design or or creating fuels or
trying to understand how plants create
fertilizers so much more efficiently
than we do and these are just too hard
to run in the lifespan of a human even
if you run a run on a fancy
supercomputer so this is a caffeine
molecule it's very hard for us to know
caffeine does what it does because it's
too big but somehow it does what it does
and probably all of you are living proof
of that
it doesn't need to run a program on a
supercomputer to tell it what to do it
just does it so quantum systems are good
at knowing what quantum systems can do
and so if we want to know what a
molecule can do or the most naive
approach might be to you might think you
just get that molecule and look at it
and then if you want to know what
happens if you prod it in a certain way
then you product and then you see what
happens but trapping and dissecting a
molecule is not like dissecting a frog
it's a much smaller and harder to reach
scale so instead what we can do is make
quantum systems that are easy to put
information in to read information out
and to manipulate so specifically
quantum systems that we want to
manipulate and then we can use those to
simulate other kinds of quantum systems
so we do this using little loops of
superconductors and they're so smaller
you can induce quantum effects on them
and you can control and via microwave
pulses so this is a well controlled
quantum system that we can use to do
quantum simulation but a very important
point is something we've known since the
the nineties is that there are other
kinds of problems that you can do on a
quantum computer so quantum computers
are universal you can compile any
computation onto a quantum computer I
always advise that you don't if you want
to play Mario Kart quantum computers are
not the place to do that if you want to
add numbers then use a normal computer
quantum computers are not gonna give you
any advantages in things like adding
numbers but there are various problems
so with one of the most famous being
factoring so if I have a number and I
want to know what prime numbers I need
to multiply to give together to get that
number this is something where
the computational effort you have to put
into that increases exponentially with
the number of digits in the number until
you get to a point where numbers are so
big that you just cannot conceivably
factor that number on any device that
exists in the lifetime of a human and
that principle is actually used behind a
lot of cryptography that it's
essentially impossible to factor numbers
and therefore we can use this as as part
of cryptography or no quantum computers
there are there is an algorithm that can
factor things much more efficiently than
that so things like factoring but also
optimization algorithms graph theoretic
problems all kinds of problems that are
abuse in all kinds of areas can be done
on a quantum computer so I would I see
it like like a graphics card you know
you don't run everything on a graphics
card but some things are better on a
graphics card so you you have the
ability to to target a graphics card
when you're running some operations when
you're running a certain problem it's
gonna be like this with quantum
computers
you're not gonna it's not gonna replace
your normal computers but sometimes as
part of whatever use case you have you
need to solve a certain problem and it's
easier just to send that out on the
cloud to a quantum computer then it
would be to do it on a non quantum
device so we have a an open source
framework now to to do quantum computing
to set up jobs to send those jobs to get
the results it's called kiss kit there
are others also available so there are a
few of these available now all but one
of them are based in Python so Python
seems to be taking off as the language
of choice for quantum computing but a
most important one as its kiss kit which
is the one that which was founded by IBM
and which is mostly developed by IBM or
we also have a lot of external
contributors
so so far I've told you how great
quantum computing is but it is very much
a technology that's on a journey in the
80s people first started because to come
up with the idea of it
so in 1981 the first conference on
physics of computation co-hosted by MIT
and IBM was kind of when quantum
computing was born and IBM was even
involved all the way back then and this
is a very IBM centric timeline so almost
every other milestone is IBM other
perspectives might write different
timelines but the company has been
involved quite a lot over the last few
decades so we've got to a point now
where we have hard prototype hardware
that's on the clouds so it's in the
hands of everyone but it's not yet okay
I would normally say I've got to adapt
to the new era now I was going to say
it's not yet possible to do anything
that a normal computer can't do but a
certain company have done some certain
results have been leaked recently that
may challenge that view but nothing you
can't do anything useful on a quantum
computer that you can't do otherwise we
haven't yet reached that goal which is I
would say the the more important one but
we're very much at a point when you can
we can start actually using the
technology to do stuff so what kind of
stuff well one thing is to plan for your
future use cases you can look at the
there's something called the quantum
algorithms ooh you can look at this and
you can that your link shouldn't be you
can look at this you can look at the
quantum algorithms ooh and you can see
the kind of things that are spread up by
quantum computer and you can go and work
out how that might impact you in the
future
and maybe look a proof of principle
applications you can do to prepare
yourself for that so we would say that a
revolution is coming and say about ten
years in terms of the usefulness of
technology and you should probably start
preparing for that now
now that the cryptography is one case
where is
to be significantly disrupted by quantum
computing and they have already been
preparing for a while but also everyone
else can get going so for example some
of my colleagues at IBM Research in
Zurich have done some proof of principle
results for quantum risk analysis so
improving risk analysis using quantum
computation so but probably the most
important use over the next few years
there will be a platform for science
that's actually how I came to it to use
IBM's
technology before I joined IBM I had a
experiment that I wanted to do and
convincing experimental physics groups
to do your experiment is very hard but
then IBM just put it on the cloud and I
could do my experiment in an afternoon
which was quite revolutionary so there's
a lot of people have been using this for
science so if you have a scientific
background in the field then it's kind
of obvious what you might do if not you
can you can still have a go at the
science so I like to liken this to the
controls of CERN being put on the
internet for anyone to fiddle around
with this is similarly one of the most
advanced pieces of experimental physics
equipment in the world and yet you can
just log into a website and drag and
drop some things and press run and and
run something on a device which is
sitting at one of the most code one of
the coldest points in the universe this
is pretty cool and I'm plugging our
rewards throughout these next few slides
so for all of the things that we we like
and which I encourage we have some
awards that we've just announced so for
people who who do those things they can
submit their work to the awards so
there's a best paper award if you are
doing science another thing is as a
platform for education so this is also
something which is also one of the use
cases for Python Python is this easy
programming language so it's great for
teaching people about programming well
quantum computing brings quantum physics
to a point where people can easily
manipulate it and use it and get hands
on with it so quantum computing in the
next few years will be a great platform
for education and we have various awards
for that we also have a textbook and
I'll be taking you through some of that
textbook today and it's also an open
source project so if you're looking for
an open source project to spend your
precious time on then Kiska is one of
them so we have an award way you could
specifically do a circuit to assert an
optimization problem which is suitable
for people who don't have a quantum
background but we also were on github
and you know there's good first issues
and there's plenty of ways to get
involved and there's plenty of people
who haven't got a quantum background
that of sort of started contributing to
this project and also you can just have
some fun so if you're a hobbyist
programmer then you might be always on
the lookout for something new and fun
too to have a go with and you can try
out quantum computing so this is kind of
the way I do things with quantum
computing a lot as well I look at how
quantum computing and games might
intersect so this is an example of a
procedural generation project that I've
done using using Kiska and if you'll
make a quantum game and there's an
awards for that as well so that is the
basics of why quantum computing exists
and now we can switch over to this again
so um now I'm going to go through some
Jupiter notebooks so whoo quick show of
hands who's got plan a working well
though this is definitely a pythonic
audience I've tried this before with
less pythonic audiences less yeah
and who's on Plan B while your signups
are great for our metric so thank you
and then plans Plan C okay fair enough
so is there any specific issues that
people want to do want to ask me B who
are in the boat of Plan C or to get
themselves that over are you happy yeah
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
is one of the firt well we have a
textbook one of our first sections of
introduction to Python and I'm sure you
all hate that section because you're
thinking this is not how you shouldn't
use people to Python well the hell kind
of syntax is that so we're not going to
do that then there's also one that's an
introduction to kids get but I'm going
to do that via this one at the moment so
this is called the atoms of computation
and really when people sometimes
programmers asking me have this quantum
computing differ from normal computing
and I think one of the main differences
is you have to start thinking at the
machine code level so if someone asks
you what see what's kind of the simplest
thing you can do in programming you
might say well print hello world or add
a couple of numbers for those oh those
are quite complicated things adding
numbers you've got to represent a number
as a bit string and then another number
is another bit string and you've got to
do all these bitwise operations between
them to generate another number my god
and the number of bits you need for
hello world
even worse so you have to kind of change
your perspective a bit and come down to
the machine code level so that means I'm
going to import some stuff here come on
so that means getting to the level of
circuit diagrams so who here is who hair
looks at that and knows what's going on
not many people so yeah circuit diagrams
is definitely somewhere to to start so
this is this is the way you can express
computation in a very simple form in
that you have these lines along which
bits travel and and then they could go
into these gates and these gates are
operations so gates are kind of like a
function this is a function with that
takes two bits of input and gives one
bit of an output and this is an
alternative kind of function that does
the same thing and so this is the
computation well this is the whole thing
it then that takes two bits of an input
a and B and then give two bits of an
output s and C and then that's your
computation so this is this is a certain
type of you know adding that's going
this is the way you can add two single
bit numbers to get 1/2 bit number so 0 0
0 at 0 will come out with 0 0 0 add 1 or
1 at 0 would come out as 0 1 and 1 1
would come out as hang on how does that
thing work again well you know we'll do
it for out so this is so if you know
what what this looks like then this is
the kind of language you'll be taking
with quantum computing but this is the
classical version this is what's
happening in your normal computers these
things here these are what transistors
do ok so i've imported my stuff that's
always good now the very heart of
quantum computing is the quantum circuit
and so it it's kind of the quantum
version of this so for this you might if
you were to make a Python object and in
fact there's I'm sure there are Python
packages based around doing
circuits but if you were to make a
quantum of if you wanted to make a
Python object which contained this sort
of structure then you might declare it
in terms of the number of inputs it has
and the number of outputs it has and
then you'll have some methods that you
can use to stick these gates in there
they call gates and hook them up so this
is basically what we need in our quantum
computing so the so we're thinking at
the machine code level that means
thinking at the level of bits so in the
classical circuit we might say how many
bits we want as input how many bits we
wanted output in quantum computing our
basic fundamental unit is called the
qubit the quantum bit and we'll look
into what they are over the course of
this and this is what we we build out of
some sort of physics in IBM we build
them out of superconductors there are
also other approaches so when we define
this fundamental object we have to say
how many qubits we want in it but also a
qubit is this weird quantum thing at the
end we want a proper output that we can
read as as non quantum animals and so at
the end we get an output which is bits
so when we set up a circuit we ask we
tell it how many qubits we want and how
many bits of output we want to get out
at the end so we define the number of
qubits we define the number of bits and
then we define our quantum circuit
object using a number of qubits and the
number of bits so over here I did from
kin-por from Kiska import star you just
want to expand along but so this quantum
circuit object is something that I
imported from here so from chriskate
import quantum circuit his what was
going on there so now I've got a quantum
circuit I can execute this and yeah if I
already use the draw methods of the
quantum circuit to show us what's
happening in that quantum circuit I get
this not much is happening we haven't
added anything to this circuit yeah
so what we can do is add in some quantum
gates so these are the basic operations
so let's add in something called
something called X and we've got two
qubits and in this particular example
and those two qubit we number qubits
from zero so they're called 0 & 1 if we
had three qubit so because 0 1 2 and so
on and so forth so it's a little bit of
a confusing case actually having two
qubits because they're called 0 & 1 but
they're also kind of right bits which is
here on one but they're not the same 0 &
1 so let's do an X on qubit one did we
already do that actually
anyway so we add these gates in but one
thing is very important is at the end of
a circuit we have to actually remember
to extract the output so what that means
is that we use this measure command and
we have two arguments to that one is the
the qubit that we are extracting the
output from and one is the bit where we
are putting the output so we have this
register of bits where we place an
output but we also have some qubits from
which we extract an output so here I'm
just saying I want qubit 0 to give me an
output and I want to put that out put on
bit 0 and then I want qubit 1 to give me
an output and then I want to put that
out put on bit 1 so when we we do this
then this is what we get as our circuit
diagram as I have a visual depiction of
what's going on in this fundamental
element of a quantum process so here we
just we've got this qubit 1 it's
straight away taking an output so cubed
0 sorry is straight away getting it an
output extracted from it qubit 1 is
having this X applied to it and then an
output is being extracted so what does
that mean well of course we'll go
through some of this in more detail but
let's get to the point where we actually
run a circuit so in kids get to run a
circuit you have to do
first decide where you're going to run
it so you've set up a back-end object so
we have different ways to set up a
back-end object but this air is where
all of our simulators live because you
can either simulate it on your actual
device because if you've not if your
circuit isn't composed of many qubits
you can simulate it quite easily if it's
composed of more qubits then it will
take more time it'll take exponentially
an exponential amount of time with the
number of qubits you have but for
something like this a two qubit circuit
is very easily to simulate so this is
the the local simulator the easiest way
to simulate things and then we run it
using the execute command so we tell the
execute command what circuit we want to
run where we want to run it and
typically we we run it for many
repetitions to get some statistics out
and then stuff happens in Kiska execute
gives you a a job object from the job
object you you run the result method to
get a results object and from the
results object you run the method to get
the exact kind of results that you want
which if you're running it all on the
simulator then you can just kind of
combine it all into one line and forget
about all that crazy [ __ ] so one so the
typical way to get results is this thing
called accounts dictionary and the
counts dictionary is basically a
histogram in the form of a Python
dictionary I'm just going to zoom in a
bit so it tells you the result you get
out and the number of times you get that
particular result so how do we interpret
this result
well it's giving us a bit string so we
have two qubits we have a circuit with
two qubits and two bits as output so
that is because we've got two bits as
output is giving us as output a two bit
string so that is what we're getting
here this is the output from our quantum
computation it is a two bit string and
we ran it a thousand times and every one
of those thousand times it gave us the
same two bit string so we've got a
pretty boring circuit here which always
gives us the same output
and why did it give us that particular
output well let's run it again but let's
this time not include any gates so this
time we are initializing two cubits and
straightaway extracting an output from
them if we do this then we always get
the result zero zero so what this is
telling us is that a cubit is always
initialized in such a way that it gives
us the output zero so if we initialize a
cubit and straight away say give me an
output it will give you an output zero
we've got two cubits and so they're both
king giving us zero and what this X gate
is doing is it's it's flipping one of
those bits from 0 to 1 so now instead of
getting 0 0 we get 1 0 because this bit
is flipped from 0 to 1 now herein lies
one of the most annoying pieces of KISS
Kip so concentrate if you were to take
that string and ask say for the first or
the element 0 of this string what
element would it give you it would give
you the 1 so the element of this string
labeled zero here is 1 but where did we
do the X we did the X on the qubit
labeled 1 and the output from the qubit
labeled 1 was put on the bit that kids
get labels 1 so the bit that kids get
labels 1 is placed in the string where
pison labels the out that element 0
basically it's um it's the UH it's the
wrong way round let's just call it what
it is it's the wrong way round so if we
added some more in here for example just
to make it so that we've what we've got
more than just 2 it's flipping this give
it 1 a ping output the output bit 1
and so this is if we asked what is the
output bit 1 of this it wouldn't give us
that one it would give us a zero so we
have to go to hang on to to get that one
so it's basically it's labeled the
labels the bits the other way around
so um yeah just be aware of that if
you're if you get confused
ever get confused with where your
outputs have gone then remember that I
told you that something weird is
happening and you'll find them so also
we have this H gate in here on qubit
zero so let's see what that does
okay well I didn't reinitialize the
object so just do it again once we use
this H gate then we start seeing some
randomness so we did it on on qubit zero
which we we output to the bit zero and
here we see the half the time it comes
out vero and half of the time it comes
out one so at this point this h gate
just seems like a coin flip that adds in
some randomness but it's not just
randomness it's more more nuance than
that as we'll see later so yeah this is
one particular way of getting results as
a effectively a histogram and a
dictionary form another way to get
results is to use instead of get counts
here to use get memory and you also need
the key word memory equals true just to
make things complicated and and then
this will give us a list an ordered list
of the results so I'll run it the first
time and then it will see what the
output is and it'll give us that and
they will run it a second time and so on
so if we just want a single output we
can just do one we can ask for the first
element of that list and you will just
get a single output every time and as
you can see because of the randomness it
changes randomly
okay so let's do something with this so
I'm going to show you how to make a
two-bit adder with kiss kit so this is a
two bit adder made with normal computing
I'm going to show you the equivalent in
kiss kit so just to motivate a two bit
adder I'll remind you how to add so I'll
take you back to your primary school
days I won't take too long about it but
I'm sure you you remember but just to
get just so we're all on the same page
of the terminology I'm using so for
example let's let's talk about a number
nine thousand two hundred and thirteen
so when we write down nine thousand two
hundred and thirteen we write a nine
than a two than a one then a 3 and why
do we do that well it's because we are
saying that it's 9,000 plus two hundreds
plus ten plus three
but why do we do that well it's because
we are used to expressing numbers in
terms of powers of 10 so 10 to the 3 is
a thousand so we're saying how many 10
to the freeze we have ten to the two is
a hundred so then we're saying how many
10 to the twos will have and then we say
how many 10 to the ones we have and then
we say how many 10 to the zeros we have
and so on so we're expressing a number
in terms of its powers of 10 but we
could equivalently express a number in
terms of viz pals of whatever and in
binary we of course use powers of two so
nine thousand two hundred and thirteen
could be expressed as 1 10 to the 13 0
10 to the 12 0 10 to the 11 0 tempted
attends 1 10 to the 9 and so on and so
forth
which means it's a binary representation
of this number is 1 there there ma no
one benefits from me reading there now
listen and this is actually why kiss kit
numbers things the way they do because
this so if you asked Python about the
zeroth element of this string it would
give you the one on this end but it's
actually the one on this end which
corresponds to 2 to the 0
and then this one corresponds to 2 to
the 1 so this is where the the kiss get
numbering of them the bitstrings comes
from it's not the kids get numbering its
well ok maybe this is the right
numbering and pythons got it wrong but
it's certainly annoying the little
there's a different way around sometimes
anyway so of course binary strings can
be represented used to represent more
than just numbers they can be used to
represent everything and then also any
computation is basically the
manipulation of binary strings and you
can you can represent all computation as
in terms of fundamental elements so just
take two bits and output a single bit so
once you have that element then you have
everything so one of the universal logic
gate is the NAND gate so this is just a
way of taking two bits as input I'm
extracting giving one bit of output and
everything can be compiled down to NAND
gates and I've even a course called NAND
to tetris which takes you from just NAND
gates to building your own operating
system to implementing games in them so
well you know if you if you if you think
NAND gates sound fun I mean who wouldn't
then you can you can have a look it up
ok so let's just look at some binary
strings in kiss clip so now we're gonna
do some fine bit strings with 8 bits
we're gonna set these up in kiss kit so
here's where I'm gonna say how many bits
there are and then I'm going to
initialize a quantum circuit which has n
qubits and n output bits often when
people in this your eyes quantum
circuits then they do just use as many
qubits as they do output bits but in
generally in quantum computing these
numbers are can be different but it'll
always be the same than what we do today
and then I want to extract
an output from each of those qubits so I
have the loop over all of my my qubits
and as one of these measure operations I
should maybe should maybe point out why
do we have to have this measure
operation well aim in quantum systems
which is what qubits are well how to say
it without sounding like a pop science
article quantum systems change when you
observe them so a measure is not a
passive Act you're not just having a
little glimpse at what it's doing and
then it continues to do what it did
forevermore when you measure something
you are you are coupling yourself to it
and you are changing you are changing
its behavior from ever more so the
moment at which you extract an output is
an important moment in the life of a
qubit and that's why we have to have
explicitly these measure operations
which is where the qubit sends a message
down into our our normal classical world
and that's why they're they're
represented in this way so this is this
is meant to be a very simple
representation as kind of like a needle
on a on a measuring device that's where
the symbol comes from and then it's
sending a message down into our into our
normal everyday world I shouldn't do
that a little bit now so this is this is
what's happening now I get eight qubits
and I immediately extract an output from
all of them and then I I want to look at
what that output is so if I go down here
what I'm gonna do is is visualize this
I'm visualizing the counts as a
histogram so if I if I just put counts
in here then it would be one of these
dictionaries if I move that up which is
the the bit string we get out and then a
number of times it came out but we can
use one of the tools from kids kit just
to make that into a histogram because
everyone else histogram
right this is a this is actually this
this talk is on the PI data stream so
you can't say you don't want histograms
so basically we're getting very there
there there well eight zeros are all of
the time and this is because as I said
earlier a qubit by default output zero
when you initialize a qubit it always
outputs zero and we're not doing
anything to these qubits we're just
extracting an output so they're all
outputting a zero now if we wanted to do
something more exciting then we could do
per gate in so here I'm putting an X
gate so here I'm doing something
slightly fancy so let's look at exactly
what I'm doing
I'm setting up a quantum circuit here
and I'm calling it QC encode and if you
look at how I'm initializing that
quantum circuit I'm initializing it with
only one argument so I'm saying here the
quantum circuit which has n qubits how
many outputs does it have I don't know
not including the prospect of extracting
an output from this circuit which is a
bit weird but you'll see how though okay
I have no output so it's completely cut
off from from us but we'll see how we
get around that later
so now I'm putting a gate into this and
this is this X gate which is effectively
a not gate it just flips the 0 to a 1 so
on qubit 7 I'm flipping that 0 into a 1
now how do I see that I've done that
well actually if you look up here I I
called this QC output and I'm basically
and this is just consisting of measures
this is just because it consisting of
operations which extract an output from
a quantum circuit so I'm going to use
this to extract outputs from the next
few circuits so basically I'm going to
take this where I do something actually
interesting I do a gate and I'm going to
add it on to this which is where I
extract outputs and it's going to allow
me to to get an output at the end so I
make a sir
which is me adding my encoding circuit
which is where I did the gate with my
output circuit which is where I'm taking
these measurement where I'm doing these
measurements and the resulting circuit
just takes the first circuit I made and
then adds on the second circuit so there
was the same number of qubits in both of
these circuits there was very
well-defined what happens when this when
I add I just basically take one of these
circuits and the other one and put them
next to each other there are many other
cases where you can you can add circuits
to do different kinds of effects but I
won't go for all of those this is just
what I'm gonna like kind of syntax if
I'm going to be using here and now if we
run this combined circuit then we get a
result that to me is unexpected ah
because I haven't executed this cell yet
so it's still remembering a qco from
earlier so here always I get out the
output one and then seven zeros just
because I flipped one of these bits from
0 to 1 and the rest of the remains here
so with this I can encode a number and
in this case I've encoded the number
which is 2 to the 7 and then I can if I
choose to I can encode other numbers so
if you want to know how old I was when I
created this notebook
I was out which I yeah
so you see wherever gone so in if you
add the output circuit to this you can
extract the actual output and you'll get
the bit string which in this case will
be 0 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 ok so this is just me
encoding binary strings in Kiska we have
not really gone anywhere quantum yet or
done anything well yeah let's say done
anything interesting
so but is everyone fine with how I'm
encoding bit strings using qubits for no
apparent reason now we can get on to
actually doing something so I've said
earlier if you want to add there's no
better computational device to add on
than the ones we already have available
to us but let's look and we're adding is
a very simple algorithm so if we're
trying to look at how to actually do
something with quantum computing then
seeing how to add it's kind of like a
very simple hello world and then from
that we can go on to do more complicated
stuff so how does one add well at
Primary School what I was taught to do
at least was to to write the numbers
that I was adding one on top of the
other and then you can go down through
the columns 3 plus 4 is 7 1 plus 5 is 6
2 plus a is 10 which means I put a 0
down here and I carried a 1 and then so
on and so forth so this this process of
adding and two numbers of arbitrary
links is compiled down to adding just
single-digit numbers mostly we just add
two single-digit numbers at a time but
in the case of a carry we add free
single-digit numbers because hereafter
do nine plus one but also carry a one so
if we have the ability to add at most
three single-digit numbers then we have
the ability to add anything and if we
have the ability to add two single-digit
numbers we can also use that to add
three single-digit numbers so this come
this operation of adding two
single-digit numbers is kind of the the
most fundamental aspect of addition if
we have the ability to do that then we
can take whatever we've used to do that
and wire it up many times to make
something that can add anything now how
does this look in binary while you just
do the same thing but
in binary so one at zero is 1 0 at 1 is
1 1 as 1 is 2 and 2 is is 1 0 so in so
in the case that we have 1 at 1 is 2 we
have to express this as 1 0 and carried
a 1 and then we have 1 as 1 as 1 is 1 1
and so on and so forth so the important
thing to note about this is that there's
basically only once we get it into
binary it becomes a lot simpler than if
you want to add two single-digit numbers
which is now which is the the
fundamental process of addition there's
only four cases you have to be able to
fulfill so if you can make some sort of
device be it made out of transistors or
or the flow of water through a channel
or whatever if you can make some sort of
device which can encode and perform this
operation then you can build any ad that
you want and so what that has to do is
for the case of 0 plus 0 it has to give
you 0 0 in the case of 0 plus 1 it has
to give you 0 1 for the case of 1 plus 0
it has to also give you 0 1 because this
is 1 in binary expressed as a 2 bit
string and in the case of 1 plus 1 it
has to give you 1 0 because this is 2 in
binary so this is a half adder and what
we saw out of top was a half adder using
boolean logic gates which is basically
what happens inside these devices what
we're gonna do is is to implement the
half adder in kiss kit so the way we're
gonna do this is by using a circuit
which looks something like this so we're
gonna have four cubits in this circuit
we're gonna have two output bits so this
is actually an exception to the rule I
said earlier and so what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna we're gonna use two of
these circuits to encode our input and
we're gonna sorry do two of these qubits
to encode our input we're gonna use the
other two qubits to extract our output
and then in the middle magic is gonna
happen so why don't we just use two
cubits and the reason is that computing
quantum quantum computations always have
to be reversible which means so if you
think of normal reversible computer
reversible operations means that
whatever whatever bit string whatever
input you give have to lead to a unique
output such that it is possible in
principle given an output to infer
exactly what the input was now with with
with adding this is not reversible in
itself because 0 + 1 + 1 + 0 these are
two separate inputs for they both lead
to the same output so if you do this
with a reversible computation you need
some sort of somewhere where you're
scribbling notes throughout the process
so this is why we need more qubits than
we have then there are bits in the
problem we just need an extra little bit
of space to ensure reversibility ah so
we're going to code our two input bits
and we encode these two input bits using
X gates so if you want 0 + 0 then we
have nothing over on the left-hand side
there so that they just go in in their
natural 0 States if we want 0 + 1 we put
an X on one of those to flip it to a 1
but leave the other one 0 and if we want
1 + 1 we put an X on both which is what
we've depicted here and then at the end
we extract outputs so what do we need to
put in the middle well let's look again
at what our half adder does in the case
so if we look at the output we need to
get from a half adder now if we look on
the the left-hand side of ok let's look
first actually on the right hand side of
these bit strings in two cases we get a
0 and in two cases we get one the two
cases where we get a 0 on the left hand
side a 0 + 0 + 1 + 1 so they're the two
cases where you add the same thing you
are
zero to zero or one to one and the two
cases where we get a 1 are 0 + 1 + 1 + 0
so that bit is basically telling us
whether our two input bits are the same
or different so that is a piece of
information that that is telling us so
we need two components to making a half
adder one is to work out whether our two
inputs are the same or different and
then if we look at the left side it is
one only in one case which is one plus
one so that part tells us are both of
our inputs one so to make a half adder
we have to out answer two questions one
is our inputs the same or different and
give a binary output output and the
other is our inputs both one or not and
those two questions are what are
answered in the in normal computing by
these two things they are basically the
things that we use to answer those two
questions this is the and gate and this
is the exclusive or exclusive all works
out whether it has the same or different
the and gate works out whether they're
both one but we are not this is I'm not
telling you about classical so well I am
telling you about classical circuits
because I just did but that is not the
point of this exercise so now we need
some other operations and so what I'm
gonna so the operation is very important
for working out whether they're the same
or different which which replicates the
exclusive-or in some sense is this thing
called the controlled not sort of
controlled so so far the only gate
you've really seen is X and X just flips
from 0 to 1 and 1 to 0 it's kind of
boring this is the control not what this
does is it acts on two qubits and it
basically looks at one qubit well okay
what does it do it does well it applies
some quantum stuff but we have to as
humans come up with some sort of story
to explain
so I'm going to tell you the story that
everyone uses but really it does some
quantum stuff there are other stories
that sound complete can completely
control victory which also explain what
I've seen nice doing but what one
usually says is the sea not has to
involves two cubits we call one of these
the control qubit and we call the other
one the target qubit and it basically
looks at the control qubit to see
whether it's a zero or a one if it's a
zero the gate itself does nothing as if
it wasn't there if the control qubit is
zero it is as if this C naught was not
even there if the control qubit was a 1
it is as if you have you applied an X to
the target so it's like a conditional
version of the X it doesn't X on the
target which is in this case qubit 1 if
the control qubit is in state 1 and if
it is in the state 0 else if it's in the
Severo it does nothing and the end
effect of this is to perform an
exclusive all and we can see this by
having it in a circuit yeah now why if
they're not an execution of this
anywhere nearby so let's execute this
execute QC we also have it already have
a back ends up we'll use a default value
of shots don't resolve can't type don't
get counts so in this specific case
we're getting 1 1 so let's look at a few
a few cases as to whether we have this X
here or not
so in this case our qubits are
initialized 0 0 it's given that this one
is initialized to be 0 this is this C
naught does nothing we extract outputs
and what do we get at the end we get 0 0
because we initialized it as 0 0
because the control is in state zero we
effectively though nothing and then we
just extract an output when we get zero
zero similarly let's apply an X to cube
it one and in this case we start off
zero zero and this here this is still in
state zero this is in state one but
because this is in state zero the
controlled-not effectively does nothing
we extract an output this gives us zero
this gives us one which means that the
result we get is 1 0 which is 1 from
this cuba and 0 from this one so again
the C naught isn't doing anything
so let's now have a case where to C
naught actually does something so here
we is starts off 0 0 we do this to make
to flip this 0 to a 1 and then this here
the control not sees that this is 1 it
springs into action by effectively doing
another X down here which means that
then when we extract the output both of
them are in state 1 so we see the
controlled not doing something and one
thing that we can note if we if we look
at different out different
implementations of this is that the
output we get on qubit one is actually
going to be the exclusive or of the
inputs that we give so if these are 0
and 0 the C naught does nothing for this
remains 0 and this is 1 and 1 then the
control not flips this one into a 0 so
in both cases where we have the inputs
here are the same the output on qubit 1
is 0 but for both cases where the inputs
are different then the output here on
qubit 1 is 1 so we get the exclusive or
we get the same or different information
that we need on qubit 1 by just doing a
controlled not so the controlled nor is
what we can use to get this same or
different information it tells us
whether these two inputs are the same or
different unfortunately that's not all
we're doing at the moment because it's
part of a an addition circuit and as I
said the form that we want
the end is for us to have two inputs and
two outputs and these the outputs are on
different qubits than the inputs so we
can't use exactly what we've got here so
what we can instead do is form a circuit
of this type so here we have two inputs
we have two outputs and our exclusive or
information is going to be down here so
we're doing two controlled knots
they're both controlled on the same
place so if you think about what's
happening here if these are both zero
neither of these control knots do
anything this one remains zero if these
are both one then both of these
controlled knots do something this
doesn't act to flip the 0 to a 1 this
does another X to flip the one to a zero
and then hence we've got two flips and
we're back to our initial zero state and
it's these are different and then one of
them flips it and the other one doesn't
so we get a 1 here so our exclusive or
information are same or different
information about the inputs is now here
and it's provided by these so-called
controlled knots which are effectively
like conditional versions of the X
operation now all we need is a next bit
of the output which is going to tell us
the other bit the carry bit of the
output which tells us where both of our
inputs were 1 so how do we do that well
we do it using something called a TOEFL
II so a toughly the easiest way to
explain it is is basically like a
controlled controlled not so this is a
controlled not it does an X here if this
isn't state 1 but it's awfully doesn't X
here if both of these are in state 1 and
then it's basically already doing the
thing we want so in this but one
particular case where these are both 1
it flips this otherwise it does nothing
and this remains 0 so then using this so
using these X gates just to flip between
zeros and ones using this controlled-not
gates to get the XOR information using
this 2
to do than the job of the Nan's this
controlled controlled form of the the X
then we have the ability to add numbers
so here is where we encode our input if
we want to do if we want to add 0 to 0
we don't do any X's here so 0 plus 0
equals drumroll 0 to 0 plus 1 which we
are encoding by having this as a 0 and
flipping this to a 1 gives us the output
1 and now I know let's get to the really
fun bit 1 plus 1 is 2 there are only
this many kinds of people in the world
those who understand binary and those
who don't so this is the very basic
level of doing something with kids yet
we're only we're already doing something
that we know how to do on normal
computers which is to to add binary
strings but it hopefully gets us into
the right mindset it gets us thinking at
the right level which is at the level of
these this bit these bitwise operations
we have to think how we are going to
encode our information in the form of a
binary string and we encode that
information and we have to think of how
we are going to manipulate our
information in the form of binary and in
this case we've done it in a way which
is exactly the same as how a normal
computer does it so we'll get no
advantage over normal computation doing
doing this but in in general in quantum
computing we take more complicated
problems and we try and doing them in a
way that is there's a better so we can
get an we can get
and output faster than we would on a
normal computation so this is the first
of the notebooks that I was going
through today and so far we have just
done we have just looked at qubits being
bits so we've completely demystified
these qubits hopefully we've taken all
of the magic out of qubits we've just
used them as bits so now we can start
looking at some of what oh yeah yeah hmm
okay yeah yeah so um Oh deal more of an
H gate in this notebook the yeah that's
an important point about let's see not I
told you earlier that the measurement
was this point where you extract an
output from a qubit and it's the most
important point in a qubits life that it
has this measurement and then I was I
was talking about the qubit the C not
there controlled not and I was talking
about it in this this way that we
usually do that the C not looks at a
qubit and based on the state does
something now this what does it mean for
a C not to look a qubit well now we're
getting into philosophy it means a
different thing for us to look at it it
means a different thing from us doing a
measurement the determinate state and
then based on the result of that
measurement doing an X that would be
called a classically controlled X and it
is different so I see not well if so a C
not can work even when the state of a
qubit is not deterministic
so even when there is some randomness as
to the zero or one state of the qubit
the C naught also works and it serves to
basically spread out that randomness so
if you have one qubit and it's random
randomly and stay 0 or 1 and you do a
see not controlled on that you
get two qubits are randomly in state 0 0
or 1 1 what are this randomness is not
their normal kind of randomness that we
we usually experience it's uh it's um
it's it's kind of the tip of a of an
iceberg and I'm gonna try and explain
the randomness inside of Cuba including
the H gate in this next notebook and in
this notebook I actually this notebook
is made so it can run on a pew pew just
because that's more Sun than not running
it on a pew pew I'm not actually gonna
run no way Soren either I'm not actually
gonna run it on a pew pew here so if you
don't know what a pew pew is there was
one in very large form on the screen in
the keynote this morning but it's it's
this it's a microprocessor based now
microcontroller based games console it's
got an 8x8 pixel screen it's got some
buttons and you can use Python 2 to make
games for it it's a great fun way of
using Python to do something it's a
great way of teaching people how to use
Python so I decided to get a quantum
simulator running on this
microcontroller so that I could use so
that people could easily make quantum
games and also it helps sort of
visualize what's going on here so I'm
gonna instead of using histograms I'm
gonna I'm gonna pretend that we've got a
pew pew up on the big screen here so
let's uh let's see if that works
and my emulator uses matplotlib because
how better to emulate a games console
and using that for navy right let's try
and get this nicely fit on the screen ok
it is fitting on the screen it just goes
big when it stops running or maybe not
okay
I'll have to flip between the tab from
between the different screens for the
controller and the screen so this is
this is a pew pew and I've set all of in
this program I've set all of the all of
the pixels to a particular kind of dim
value except for that one over there
which is bright and we're going to be
using actually that pixel down there to
display the output of a qubit and we're
going to use the controllers to to
manipulate this cuba so well I won't go
through the how pew pew is work because
we don't have that much time but here is
so here is the I'm using a qubit
initially and this is initially in state
zero and I'm going to represent the
binary up of this qubit as the
brightness of that pixel down there so
if I press up on my game pads come on
work work if I press up nothing works
okay change of plan that would be the
the funnest way to do it if it worked
but let's not spend too long making it
work on this big screen it is a tiny bit
flaky so instead we'll go through this
notebook and I'm just going to do it
ecstatically
this is from the web so the important
thing about qubits is they oh they are
quantum objects and there's quantum
objects they obey Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle so here we here we
go with with the last portion of this
workshop which is a lecture in quantum
mechanics and we begin with Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle so if you know if
you've ever ever heard about quantum you
might have heard about this No
of the uncertainty principle which means
that for a quantum object for example
you cannot precisely know both its
position and its moment if you know it's
in theory if you know it's precision if
its position with absolute precision
then its momentum is completely
uncertain and if you know its momentum
with absolute precision then its
position is completely uncertain it's
randomly anywhere in the universe so
quantum qubits a quantum objects when
they obey this uncertainty principle but
I don't have position and momentum the
only quantities related to a qubit
binary outputs it gives you zeros and
ones so the way that we we get their
uncertainty principle with qubits is by
noting that this operation that we've
been performing this measure operation
it's not the only way of extracting an
output from a qubit so it is a way of
extracting an output from a qubit is a
way of inducing a qubit to tell us
whoever is a 0 or a 1 but it's not the
only way and if you go to our
cloud-based service and you and you use
the GUI there and still have on our
matplotlib we're visualizing things it
looks like oh now even though I've given
up on this it's still running in the
background and it's causing my fans to
start going a little bit mad so I'll
just shut that down on them and the
symbol is this so it's the same except
it has this edge here so the reason for
this is that this is if you look on this
this version is a hint that it's not the
only way to extract an output so this is
this is one way to extract an output but
there is also another way and the other
way it's called so the normal way which
you get by just doing a measure gate is
called a Zed measurement so this way of
extracting an output score as this
measurement this alternative way is
called an X measurement so you did and
you can implement it like this by just
doing
and H whatever that is with a I haven't
yet explained that and then omission now
why does this work well it does and to
be honest if I had more power in kiss
kit there wouldn't be a measure
operation it would be measure underscore
Z or something like that so you're
explicitly saying it's a Zed measurement
and you'd do this by using measure
underscore X so that I don't so we're
stuck with it the physics of the device
means that one of these types of
measurements is very easy to actually do
in terms actually implement so with our
actual qubits you
we always extract a measurement using a
third measurement and we have to kind of
use hacky ways to do the other
measurements but in terms of the actual
the theory behind qubits this is a
distinct way of extracting a measurement
extracting an output sorry so this is
another way we can extract an output
from a qubit and so there's different
ways we can extract an output but the
important thing about a qubit is it can
only store a bit of information so you
can't use these two ways of getting an
output to extract two different bits you
can't you can't fool it into a story
more information than it really can it
can only store a bits worth of
information so to see this let's start
let's create a circuit QC 0 which is
just an empty circuit let's send do an X
measurement of this circuit and run it
and what does it give us well we've been
doing this the whole session so far if
you take a cube it and you straightaway
extract an output it will give you a 0
so this gives us 0 the whole time
but if we instead instead of extracting
this output using the red measurement if
we instead instead extract it using the
X measurement and we look at the output
then it will randomly be either 0 or 1
so this is an important principle of
qubits unlike bits which are 0 or 1 and
there's basically there's only one way
to ask
a bit sorry there's only one way to ask
a bit whether it's zero or one and
that's just to look at whether it's zero
or one but with a qubit there's
different ways to extract the output
it's use and if you prepare something
which is definitely gonna give you zero
for a Zed measurement which is what we
had here and you instead do an X
measurement the result is completely
random so you're getting a random output
for the X measurement even though the
the result would have been definite for
a Zed measurement I know this is a
little bit abstract but uh you know this
is a quantum computing session so it
does have to come in at some point now
we can try doing this each gate which
I've kind of introduced a little bit
before but we've we've not really looked
to much of it so if I take a circuit and
I make it an empty circuit and the only
thing I do to it is an H gate we can
look at what effect that has so now
let's extract an output just from that
and we've got two ways of extracting an
output so one of those ways is to do a
Zed measurement which is our normal way
of extracting an output and we get a
random result so what is this HK is it
like a coin flip which just makes stuff
random well no because if we instead
take that same circuit and do an X
measurement then we get a definite
result it always comes out zero so what
the H has effectively done is just moved
the certainty we had a qubit which was
very certain about the output it would
give for a Zed measurement and we made
it instead very certain about the output
it would give for an X measurement and
the other one is always random so it is
a two different ways of extracting an
output and they can't simultaneously be
certain about what they're going to give
but we can move the certainty around
between them one of them can be
certainly everyone not now we can also
look at other gates so there's something
called a wire rotation which you can do
by doing R Y you can specify the qubit
that you're acting on and then you can
you can you you put in an angle in
radians which I
just putting pie by minus pie by four
and for this particular example if I
take now this circuit and I measure it
in the users head measurement of that
then what the output I get is 87 percent
of the time it comes out zero and
thirteen percent of the time it comes
out one so it's mostly certain that it's
going to be a 1 but not entirely certain
if we instead do it X measurement yeah
in this case it's mostly certain it's
going to be a 1 it's not entirely
certain so we can also kind of share out
this certainty between it but the
certainty that a cubit holds is o is a
conserved quantity it can only be so I
only have so much certainty and you we
can either make the output of a Zed
measurement certain or we can make the
output of a next measurement certain or
we can have a compromise between the two
but there is a conserved amount of
certainty in there so that is basically
why one way in which qubits are
different from normal bits and usually
this will be explained in terms of
superposition I don't really like the
term superposition because it refers to
what's going on in in the mathematics in
the linear algebra so if you want to get
into the linear algebra then you'll see
a superposition but in if we if we do it
without the linear algebra we just look
at the the behavior of a cuba it sits
like this it has could we have multiple
ways of extracting outputs and we have a
conserved amount of certainty and
basically making quantum algorithms is
about ship moving this certainty around
in certain ways that we get are our
input that we've encoded in there and
it's certain about our input and then
moving it around them certain ways to
get our output and this is a completely
different approach to creating
algorithms than we usually have in a
normal computing so I've just been told
that we're coming to the end how long do
I have how
do I have five minutes okay so I can't
explain 50 years of progress in
theoretical physics in five minutes ten
minutes maybe I could have done it but
okay ten minutes I could well ten
minutes I say ten minutes maybe I could
have done it to make myself seem like a
great teacher but maybe ten minutes is
also a little bit but basically yeah if
we if we use the controlled-not
let's go back to somewhere we can
actually execute code so now let's do a
two qubit circuit quantum circuit - -
and and then we do a Hallam odds so this
H gate and then we do a controlled not
and
well I've just done the ASCII version
there rather than the matplotlib so it
doesn't look quite as nice but what is
this gonna output so this is if we think
of it about it in terms of outputs for
Zed measurements and this is randomly
either 0 or 1 so this is gonna if it
sees a random 0 it will do nothing here
and keep this 0 if it sees a 1 it will
flip this to a 1 so what we would then
expect and I can't be bothered to write
out the execute command so let's just
steal it from somewhere else or I will
need to put measurement gates in of
course if we put some measurement gets
in here QC dope measure so I'm just
gonna put some Zed measurements in QC
doc measure and then I run that then it
gives us what I just predicted if either
randomly 0 0 or 1 1 so it's created
something which is random but also
correlated
[Music]
if we instead were to do X measurements
here which we can do by just having QC
the h0 and QC the h1 when I'll start
that from the beginning so in this case
I'm so before I was taking this circuit
and doing Zed outputs and they gave me
randomly over 0 0 1 1 here I do X output
I use X measurements instead I extract
Li output in this other way it also
gives me randomly 0 0 or 1 1 and it's
kind of weird so one thing that's
telling us is if you look at each qubit
individually it doesn't matter if you're
using a Zed measurement or an experiment
it's giving me a random result and the
reason for this is now the again it's
it's certainty there's there's a certain
amount of certainty contained within
qubits and by using operations we move
that certainty around it started off
that they were both certain that if you
get if you did a Zed measurement you
would get the output 0 and now we find
that if we do that measurements of both
for X measurements of both in both cases
its correlated so here we have a
certainty that the outputs are going to
be the same the outputs themselves are
random but we have the certainty that
they're going to be the same so we have
instead made ourselves certain about
certain factors of the combination of
the two qubits instead of the qubits on
their own so if we start using
controlled nots when we don't have
certainty on it to the qubits and we we
run into these interesting effects and
actually these effects have things that
are beyond what any normal variables and
normal computers can do so if you look
in that in that section of the others
the Kiska textbook there's an example
like because you might think well a
qubit is like a bit but from what I've
told you about a qubit it's kind of like
a bit but with a random number generator
attached you could probably very easily
write something that reproduces the kind
of properties of qubits that I told you
about today
and it tempts you to think that maybe
qubits are just equivalent to some pile
of bits just like dicks are or lists are
or in sorrow anything in aa but um
qubits are a type of variable are
fundamentally different from any kind of
variable that we have in normal
computers and it's when we start getting
a little bit more into involved into how
information it moves around inside these
things that we can start seeing now so
I'll have to refer you to that to look
into afterwards because we don't have
enough time for now so one thing I will
just touch upon before I stop is that if
you want to do something interesting
with a qubit with with quantum computing
then to do something that a normal
computer can't you need about 50 cubits
and you need maybe a fancy algorithm if
you want to do something interesting fun
then one qubit is enough so if you look
if you experiment with one qubit then
with that you can you can do some I've
got a suggestion for some procedural
generation that you can do so if you
want to look into that afterwards as
your first example of doing something in
kiss kit then that's something you only
need one qubit you don't need any
physics knowledge but you can do
something that's kind of fun and in fact
this last weekend was Ludum dare a which
is a game jam so if I made a a game for
that game jam which was based on my
procedural generation project serves my
final thing I'm gonna I'm gonna make
that run so it's a game now the theme
for the game jam was start with nothing
so it's procedural generation which
initially has no seed so you start you
create the world as you move around on
it and the procedural generation for
this it's very simple but it was done
using kiss kit using just one qubit
so this is the kind of thing you can do
with only one Koopa it's not gonna it's
not gonna cure cancer
but uh
it might be fun and then that can be a
first step if you want to start looking
at the kind of things that you might be
able to do with kiss get over the next
decade and also when the revolution
comes so that's that's basically all
I've got to tell you thank you for
listening
[Applause]
any questions
what the yeah so no missing no yes yes
is the answer I think what I the gates
of I had were a universal gate sir which
means that they could on their own do
everything but there are much more gates
and in fact maybe one thing to leave you
with is I have this sort of gamified and
duper a notebook based game that you can
use to get an introduction to all of the
gates and it's called hello Quantum so
if you go to IBM dot this slash hello
quantum and that that's a way of finding
out more about all of the gates the yeah
there are there are more but um they
take that same sort of general form
anymore okay well hopefully you are
motivated to look into some of the other
resources that I provided and thank you
for coming